we have a voicemail number and that
number is two one nine two david p let's
take a listen to a voicemail i received
i my local counties are upping the age
for tobacco consumption up to twenty one
i'd really like to hear you guys a
opinion on this i'm not necessarily for
this they're against this i totally see
how this could be a good thing to
curbing cancer and things like that
however i do worry that we're becoming a
state where certain things are not
allowed until you're 21 while the
ability to fight wars and no one died
for this country is still totally you
know not only available but something to
be proud of yeah ok age of eighteen so
we've talked about most of these
elements many times number one is there
an incongruity between the drinking age
and the smoking age and the age to join
the military and the driving age
whatever that's one element to this then
there's the whole well this is just
generally raising the age from 18 to 21
is nanny state stuff well eight having
it at eighteen as opposed to nothing is
also nanny state stuff you're just
getting into a matter of degrees which
is at wit where does the nanny state
choose a number we know that when you
raise the smoking age yeah some people
will go to the next town over to buy
cigarettes when they're 18 19 and 20 if
you raise it to 21 but some won't and 16
year olds who were used to having their
18 year old friends buy them cigarettes
now both the 16 and the 18 year old need
to find a 21 year old to go buy them
cigarettes so it does this make it so
that no one smokes of course not but we
know statistically speaking it does curb
smoking rates and we also know that if
you delay when someone has their first
cigarette you make it much less likely
that they will take up smoking at all so
you can have a sort of ideological
discussion about whether the government
should be involved in this at all
whether cigarettes should be legal at
all or not and if so marijuana maybe
should be legal there's a sort of a lot
of questions but the data is pretty
clear that when you raise the
smoking age you are actually reducing
the number of people who smoke yeah and
that's a good thing I don't think they
should be legal at all and as someone
who was once 18 no 18 year olds should
not be able to buy cigarettes and as far
as fighting for your country goes you
know fighting for your country is in
theory a good thing and an important
thing cigarettes if I believe your
country chooses the right back if right
right I mean that's a separate story
cigarettes there's nothing good about
cigarettes and there's nothing to be
proud of about cigarettes so let's just
remove the drinking age like many
European countries okay our soldiers can
drink well I know but remove I mean a
lot of countries when you're 16 I think
you can start to have wine and beer for
movies or loose laws I mean you you know
you can still go have wine with dinner
at restaurant no matter what your age
your parents cave in it oh yeah you can
bathe in it and so let's do that and our
soldiers can have their drinks and we
don't need cigarettes all right Jason
you want to comment on in 21 vs. 18 so
what I think happens here is now all
these 18 year olds are gonna find 21
year olds and their relative buying
cigarettes they're gonna get booze and
cigarettes every time okay that's my
theory
it'd be like before they hit they needed
different people to get them each thing
but now they can just go to 21 year olds
and do like a bulk purchase of the
cigarettes and the alcohol it's an idea
no it's an interesting point we have a
fantastic bonus show today one story has
to do with a robot spreading feces
around someone's apartment but that's
all I'm gonna tell you it's a huge huge
bonus show david pakman.com slash
membership